[Música]
y es que ya son más de dos millones de
personas las que huyen de esta
catástrofe las guerras de todos los
bombardeos también se están acordando
estos corredores humanitarios en ucrania
que pues los ucranianos dicen que ellos
quieren llegar hasta europa pero rusia
solo avala cinco corredores humanitarios
para que llegan a sus territorios
territorios rusos y también de belarús
las mujeres como también lo estamos
hablando son lamentablemente las más
afectadas por esta guerra también en los
niños y los adolescentes son las
personas más vulnerables recordemos que
también por toda esta ley marcial que
está actualmente en ucrania los hombres
no pueden dejar el país por lo que son
las mujeres las que tienen que huir
hacia europa u otros territorios solas
con el cargo de su familia de sus
familias en los brazos con toda esta
responsabilidad y también la
preocupación de haber dejado a sus hijos
ya sus esposos en territorio en
territorio ucraniano para que ellos
defiendan el país de esta invasión rusa
es una verdadera catástrofe además
también recordemos que el jefe de la
diplomacia europea
borrell aseguró que los países del
bloque de comunitario tienen que estar
preparados para recibir hasta 5 millones
de refugiados y es que cada día son las
imágenes que vemos nosotros cientos de
miles de personas son los que están
huyendo de este conflicto armado y hoy
por ser 8 de marzo día internacional de
los derechos de la mujer nos queremos
enfocar en ellas esto con nuestra
segunda invitada ella es maría jesús
vega portavoz de acnur en españa mira
jesús gracias por estar nuevamente con
nosotros en este espacio de france 24
llamado directo américa hablemos
entonces de la situación como lo ven
ustedes desde acnur la situación de las
mujeres que escapan de esta guerra de
ucrania primero y luego hablamos de las
que se quedan pero primero hablemos de
las desplazadas manejos
pues la situación verdaderamente es
dramática porque más a medida que va
pasando el tiempo y hay más incursiones
militares más bombardeos más destrucción
en las probabilidades de que haya daños
colaterales para la población civil son
y son mayores nosotros estamos pues
trabajando con el equipo de naciones
unidas dentro del país llevando ayuda
humanitaria a la zona está la zona
centro trabajando con el gobierno de
ucrania para establecer espacios seguros
donde puedan alcanzar y donde puedan
alojarse los desplazados internos y
donde estamos llevando ayuda humanitaria
pues desde colchones tiendas
mantas térmicas porque no nos olvidemos
que allí están a temperaturas bajo cero
y efectivamente en estas situaciones de
conflicto la violencia especialmente
contra las mujeres y contra niñas
muy habitual y por eso es es fundamental
el que se cuente con los recursos
adecuados para poder hacer frente a esta
situación y proteger a los grupos más
mucho más vulnerables maria jose pero
como hacen ustedes entonces para llegar
para llevar esta ayuda al terreno
ucraniano recordemos que estos
corredores humanitarios que por donde
también son donde pasan la ayuda
humanitaria pues no están funcionando
del todo ya las autoridades también
ucranianas están afirmando que rusia no
respeta estos corredores humanitarios
hemos visto también vídeos donde
bombardean a civiles en estos corredores
como hacen ustedes para protegerse para
proteger a los civiles y que realmente
esta ayuda llegue además como esta ayuda
también llega a los refugios donde hay
miles de personas escondidas para que no
les caigan estas bombas encima
y ciertamente hay gente que no nos
imagina lo que significa trabajar en un
contexto de conflicto donde tienes
puentes destruidos carreteras cortadas
check points donde hay fuego cruzado y
donde muchas veces los humanitarios
tienen que estar escondidos en los
mismos búnker que la población civil
porque están cayendo bombas y se tienen
que proteger y muertos nos servimos para
nada pero no obstante estamos tenemos
pre posicionada ayuda humanitaria en
distintos puntos de todo el país hemos
llevado ya ayuda trabajamos con el
equipo de naciones unidas pero
evidentemente lo que estamos esperando
con con muchísimo interés son esos pasos
seguros esos corredores humanitarios que
permiten dar un respiro a la población
civil que permiten trasladar a gente que
voluntariamente quiere pasar de una zona
de conflicto a una zona más segura y que
permiten que en esos momentos también
los humanitarios podamos hacer nuestro
trabajo que es lo que pedimos que se nos
deje trabajar y llevar esta ayuda
humanitaria que tanto se necesita
en ese trabajo estamos coordinando con
como digo con el equipo de naciones
unidas y en concreto las negociaciones
sobre cuáles son los corredores en qué
momento en que el lugar geográfico a qué
hora y con qué condiciones se van a
respetar por parte de ambas partes lo
está gestionando el comité internacional
de la cruz roja con la ocha acnur lleva
desde el año 94 presente en ucrania y
como digo hemos llevado ya materiales
pero no estamos pudiendo trabajar de una
manera completamente libre y acceder a
toda la población que lo necesita que
calculamos pueden llegar a 12 millones
de seguir esta situación así que maría
jesús yo entiendo todo este tema de la
ayuda humanitaria pero también hay un
punto muy importante y es la ayuda
psicológica que a lo mejor ustedes como
acnur o puedan prestar ustedes prestan
ese servicio a los refugiados sobre todo
a las mujeres de toda esta tragedia de
la guerra que evidentemente pues también
afecta a la salud mental que diría yo
que sería lo primero lo primordial que
afecta a ver toda tu casa destruida a tu
país destruido dejar a tus seres
queridos
a tus familiares muertos en esta guerra
ustedes también se enfocan en trabajar
la salud mental de las personas
así es de hecho nuestros equipos que
están en las fronteras apoyando a los
países que están recibiendo ese mayor
número de estos dos millones de
refugiados que han salido ya una parte
de los equipos están justamente dando
ese apoyo psicosocial vemos bueno pues
esas mujeres que llegan con sus hijos
con los hijos de sus de sus hermanas o
de sus primas que no pudieron salir y
que se los están llevando a ellas y
bueno hay veces que nos dice mira no
tengo ni fuerza para llorar porque no me
quiero venir abajo no me quiero hundir
delante de los niños para que ellos no
vivan está esta situación así a veces se
trata de edulcorar un poco esa vivencia
de esa realidad pero claro han vivido
situaciones dramáticas a veces han sido
ellas víctimas de esa situación han
visto morir a personas y necesitan ese
apoyo muchas veces no solo a la entrada
sino cuando ya han llegado a un lugar
seguro y cuando de repente el cuerpo te
hace un descanso y dice ya estoy a salvo
ya están mis hijos a salvo es cuando te
surgen
estrés postraumático cuando a veces los
niños dejan de hablar cuando a veces
empiezan a mojar la cama o tienen
algunos problemas de relación es
importante trabajar con las mujeres es
importante trabajar con las niñas
también y bueno pues es dar ese apoyo
psicológico que a veces es tan necesario
como comer o como proporcionar agua o un
cobijo porque además también muchas
veces nos enfocamos en las trincheras
pero este es un problema mayor además un
problema más perdurable en el tiempo y
son todas estas consecuencias
emocionales que deja una guerra que deja
un conflicto armado maría jesús no la
quiero despedir sin antes preguntarle si
en este momento ustedes han recibido
algún tipo de denuncias por por parte de
mujeres u otras organizaciones de
violencia sexual contra ellas en este
conflicto armado porque recordemos que
en el pasado pues sí ha dado y yo pues
tenía esa duda y quería saber si ustedes
tenían conocimiento al respecto
bueno tenemos equipos especializados de
acnur gente formada en temas de género
profesionales que tienen una experiencia
de trabajo con mujeres víctimas de
violencia sexual de género a nivel
físico a nivel psicológico y están
también ayudando a estas autoridades que
están recibiendo generosamente a todos
estos refugiados cuando hay alguna se
detecta algún caso que se piensa que
podría ser una persona que a lo mejor
viene acompañada de alguien que no es su
familiar o ves cualquier síntoma raro
enseguida se hace una derivación para
asegurarnos que tanto ellas como
posibles niñas o niños que llegan no
acompañados a la frontera y que cada vez
son más estén protegidos protegidos
contra redes de tráfico de trata de
seres humanos que sabemos perfectamente
que en estas situaciones se aprovechan
de la desgracia ajena así que estamos
ahí dando también apoyo con equipos como
digo expertos para identificación de
posibles víctimas de trata o tratamiento
de personas con violencia que hayan
sufrido violencia sexual
aunque no se presente en estos casos
maría jesús muchísimas gracias por su
tiempo por estar nuevamente con nosotros
en este espacio de france 24 directo
américa un gran abrazo desde bogotá
gracias a vosotros